une communauté sans gouvernement sans
monnaies habité par toutes les
nationalités
voici le projet d'oroville en inde ici
pas de racisme
noirs blancs juifs non juifs musulmans
non musulmans nous sommes tous sur le
même pied de fraternité auroville a été
fondée en 1968 par une française de
pondichéry mira alfassa aussi appelé la
mère
le nom de la ville fait référence à son
compagnon décédé ce trio robin d'eau et
à sa pensée
un yoga dit intégral cherchant
l'harmonie dans tous les aspects de la
vie là bas
[Musique]
v
abaca tous vos amis et quand on entend
la mère est décédée en 1973
or ville s'est développée après sa
disparition la cité construit un pont
entre l'orient spirituel et l'occident
matérialiste cette communauté
expérimentale s'est développé avec le
soutien de l'unesco sortie du désert
elle se bâtit au fil du temps façonné
par les nouveaux résidents en 1973 ils
sont mille or vignes j'ai trouvé ici
l'endroit où on pouvait réellement
s'exprimer en toute liberté
monsieur en ville depuis trois ans et je
cherche la vérité
je suis ici parce que je me suis senti
appelé ces hommes ces femmes ont
l'ambition de bâtir une humanité
nouvelle pour s'installer à auroville
ils ont dû renoncer à la propriété
privée céder leur bien à la communauté
auroville n'a pas de monnaie en son sein
mais elle produit pour vendre à
l'extérieur du papier de l'encens ou des
poteries par exemple le travail que nous
faisons nous le faisons bénévolement et
ce n'est pas dans le but de gagner de
l'argent ou pour
ça titre et une hiérarchie c'est
simplement parce que le travail nous
plaît que nous le faisons au coeur de
nos villes se construit le mât trimant
dire maison de la mer une géode
lieux de méditation tout autour la cité
grandi elle ce verdit dans le but
d'accueillir à terme 50 mille résidents
mais l'utopie mystique n'est pas à la
hauteur des espérances en 1990 après 22
ans d'existence
ils ne sont que sept cents à habiter
auroville néanmoins l'expérimentation
continuent ils à l'atteinte de cette
espèce de fascination de voir ce que ça
va être quand avec fini maintes fois
menacé et jugé sectaire par certains
l'expérience de rv il a résisté dans les
sociétés occidentales
auroville attire à nouveau de mille neuf
cent cinquante habitants en 2019 et une
centaine de candidatures chaque année
pour participer à l'expérimentation
utopique
[Musique]